hello everyone I hope you're all ready
for the Blitz part of the st. Louis
tournament but till that time comes I
decided to show you one game by the
former world the Women's Champion
Alexandra sustaining and here are a
couple of fun facts for you about
Alexandra and not many of you may know
this she actually acted in one movie by
the Russian director stanislav
overlooking i can't really remember the
name of the movie if some of you know do
share in the comments and she also
worked as a model so when you think
about it you know world chess champion
working as a model it does sound like a
certain guy from Norway and speaking of
Magnus Carlsen Alexandra Seneca defeated
Magnus Carlsen with the black pieces in
the 2009 world bliss championship but
this this game she's playing against the
Dutch correspondence chess champion
Carol Peter Gow and well it's an
interesting game because it gives you
another another idea on how to play it
into the French and if you're having
problems playing against the French with
the white pieces then you may try this
in some of your own games so let's see
the game we have E 4 by Alexandra we
have e 6 the French defence and now I'm
not going for for the center right away
would be for she plays Knight to f3
we have d5 Knight to c3 and our Bishop
to b4 and now he five we have 97 h4 and
now c5 and unlike the b5 threatening
Knight to d6 check bow castles and
simply C 3 we have Bishop to a5 and now
D for a six-night jumps to b6 and seek
after Sundy for and here our custom
doesn't capture the pawn back but she
plays Bishop to the Bishop to d3 and if
she invites black to capture on c3 and
or you know go for a complicated game
which he does he plays D captors on c3
and as you can see here this is a pretty
standard set of PFF queen and d1 bishop
from d3 nice on f3 and this h4 pawn is
definitely a plus and Kristina plays
Bishop captures on h7 and well let's see
what would happen if black would accept
this Bishop Sakura
if King captures on h7 then Knight to g5
check and of course if the King goes
back then simply Queen to h5 and it's
checkmate on h7 so the King has to go to
g6 and now this h5 move and the King has
to go to h6 and here he is being spent
here from this bishop on c1 but well it
does seem like Weiss can capture this
pawn on f7 and this will win a queen of
course but black is also threatening to
capture on b2 which check and get get a
queen on a one of his own
so simply be four here would be played
and after Bishop captures here on before
black is still threatening this move but
now simply Queen to c2 and now life is
doing the threat of nice captures on f7
is still here but also this Queen as she
is blocking the c3 pawn she is also
threatening Queen h7 checkmate
so black would have to block checkmate
with Knight to a5 and now simply Knight
captures on f7 row captures on f7 and
the other night captures on f7 which
check for King the king and queen and
this is over King h7 and night captors
and e8 so of course black saw this and
after Bishop captures on h7 played King
tha - the only move and now we have King
to f1 an interesting move by sustain
getting out of this pin we have a seek
after some B 2 and C capture some b2 we
have f6 and now another beautiful move
by Stanwyck nice g5 again going for this
night to f7 threat disregarding this f6
pawn that's why I say that this h4 point
is a big plus you know almost all the
variations so the knight has to be
captured F captures ng v HK and now
sorry Queen to h5 now threatening Bishop
to g6 check and with a checkmate on h7
so we have a nice - g8 and now simply
special character sign g8 in captures on
g8 and H captures and g5 and now of
course the thread is Queen - h7 or
Queens HHH checkmate and well this can't
really be stopped it can only be
prolonged the black plays one more move
rook captures an f2 and f4 team captures
and has two black resigned
so it seems like maybe maybe classical
Chester was a bit too fast for for these
guys he was a correspondence chess
champion and yeah that's it I do hope
you enjoyed this game and oh yeah one
other thing I'll accept the Christina
who won the world European Championship
in 2004 and she was awarded the
international Grandmaster title for this
achievement and she was the Tempur woman
in in chess history to achieve this to
achieve this title and in 2008 she won
the world's women championship and in
the finals she defeated the young
Chinese prodigy holy fun and was it was
a pretty pretty tough game I mean I
pretty tough match she won with a result
of two and a half to one and a half so
as you can see even from a very young
age who even was already contending for
the for the title so yeah that's it I do
hope you enjoyed this game as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
and I would like to thank Douglas twice
thanks for contribution to my channel I
do appreciate it
and well that's it see you soon guys